[Musique]
bonsoir à tous trois raisons trois
bonnes raisons me semble-t-il de
regarder cette émission d'abord c'est la
100e
ensuite le sujet de circonstance
l'humour qu'on est plutôt content et
puis enfin l'invité de référence c'est
françoise sagan françoise sagan vous
publié chez julliard hanté et toute ma
sympathie je butais dessus treize textes
dans lesquels on aime vous retrouver on
aime retrouver ce que ce qu'on aime lire
dans un beau livre c'est à dire on vous
retrouve avec la votre lucidité votre
courage votre fermeté votre enthousiasme
votre humour beaucoup d'humour et un peu
de mélancolie bien sûr aussi puis
évidemment toujours ce fameux ton ce
fameux style sagan alors l'un des textes
est une
c'est un portrait de catherine deneuve
vous êtes allé la voir vous avez son
interview pour un son portrait pour un
magazine et un moment dans l'entretien
vous avez eu avec elle vous lui avez
demandé cette question comment
aimeriez-vous que soit le papier que je
vais faire pour vous alors j'ai envie de
vous demander où le maintenant je vous
imitent comment aimeriez-vous que soit
cette émission dont vous êtes invités de
référence eh bien je la vérité comme aux
émissions en général bon va coûter assez
vous demandez rien de particulier non
c'est un homme très bien alors puisque
la merci puisque l'un de vos textes
étaient consacrés à la télévision il est
fort drôle nous allons parler de
télévision avec mireille qui évoquera
son mari emmanuel berl qui a été le
premier écrivain critique de la
télévision à faire la critique de la
télévision des programmes
alain rémond qui est le critique de
télévision de télérama sous le titre sa
rubrique est bien connu mon oeil
et j'ajoute que vous verrez une parodie
de bouillon de culture à la mode
d'aujourd'hui dans quelques minutes
et puis puisque françoise sagan vous
évoquez le cinéma à travers trois grands
personnages c'est à catherine deneuve
ava gardner et federico fellini j'ai
invité sam karmann qui a réalisé un
court métrage un petit chef-d'oeuvre
fort amusant l'intitulé omnibus et ce
court métrage qui devrait vous a
remporté la palme d'or à cannes et l'
oscar à hollywood qui est quand même pas
rien et bien ce court métrage ce sera le
cadeau de cette centième numéro de
bouillon de culture nous le verrons tout
à l'heure et autres cadeaux michael
nyman qui est le compositeur de la leçon
de piano
fameux film de jane campion qui a obtenu
la palme d'or à cannes et qui est qui
obtient un succès considérable
actuellement en france et vous ne
jouerez la gentillesse de jouer alors un
petit morceau donc de la leçon de piano
et enfin cabu pour l'humour qui est
revenue du japon avec des dessins et un
livre et qui entend nous freine un
dessin pour illustrer cette émission
alors françoise sagan et toute ma
sympathie sort neuf ans après avec mon
meilleur souvenir avec mon meilleur
souvenir sert deux livres dans lesquels
on trouve des portraits de gens vous
avez rencontré que vous aimez beaucoup
et en même temps vous en profitez pour
parler de vous-même peut se demander si
son pavé un peu des mémoires des
déguisés éparpillés disséminés malin
toute façon navire je crois pas de moi
même je parle dans le premier des gens
que j'admire et dans le deuxième des
gens qui ne font plus que j'ai admiré
par la suite
ouais mais c'est pas avec vous même
aussi nous vous en lisant vous pensez
vous voyez derrière mais moi en écrivant
je pense uniquement aux gens vous choisi
parce qu'il vende ses lecteurs oui bah
oui c'est vrai c'est vraiment moi je
pense pas du tout faire un portrait de
moi même
en fait je parle plutôt de précisément
de quatre niveaux de créer ni 100 m sont
donnés des répliques brillante non c'est
vrai mais en même temps quand même on
voit où on vous voit vivre derrière on
voit vos goûts votre sympathie parfois
beau non je trouve ça intéressant alors
il est vrai que le cid dans deux ou
trois ans vous publiez c'est leur aide
pour le mans de votre éditeur françoise
sagan mémoire aéro livre de 400 pages
alors là ça ferait un succès n'ont
jamais fait mais pourquoi je mets n'ont
jamais je prendrai
je connais moi et pourquoi j'en ai pas
beaucoup je vois je m'en fout de nous
deuxièmement de seulement jours de la
panne sans vision d merci c'est pas bon
ça complique les choses
faux très discret ça mais tout par terre
et troisièmement je serai peut-être en
prison a posteriori alors donc vous
envoyez votre sympathie aux lecteurs
dans ses derniers livres et les
critiques unanimement vous envoient leur
admiration
cc oui peut-être jamais comme août non
hein c'est à dire très sincèrement ce
que c'était souvent agréable d'être
considéré comme un écrivain
oui et donc c'est vrai c'est assez
plaisant
oui alors ce qui est vrai c'est que à un
certain moment vous aviez dit ah les
critiques c'est incroyable il me
considère toujours
enfin il quand il parle de moi c'est
comme si j'ai deux s'il était mon moment
mais mes oncles
oui mais surtout il parlait de moi et
parce que j'écrivais il parler de ton
personnage de 8 par rapport à ce que
l'énervement que le procès de mythe cela
général par rapport au sila qui par
rapport à toute nation du cfp très
rarement de ce que j'avais écrit et des
boues quoi et la désigne en général sont
plus parler du lit ce qui est vrai c'est
que tantôt on vous considère comme un
phénomène de société tantôt comme un
écrivain et semble aujourd'hui
mais comment expliquer cela que vous
êtes il était temps que vous êtes
vraiment un écrivain est de moins en
moins phénomène de société c'est un
mélange d'une moindre vêtement mon côté
têtu et le côté petit avec y compris
aussi il ya peut-être aussi les années
qui passent
peut-être qu'ils gardent plus en plus
rien oui plus en plus sérieux et que et
peut-être les critiques aussi fait c'est
peut-être de plus en plus sérieux non
mais vous avez dit quelque part aussi
que vous
vous ne saviez pas si vous resteriez
alors là beaucoup plus tard comme
écrivain comme phénomène de société
je ne sais pas peut-être aujourd'hui
c'est espérer cité comme un crime en
même temps oui mais oui mais c'est bien
d'autres passions vous êtes sûr de
rester j'ai une chance j'aimerais
sérieusement et j'ai une chance de
confirmer une société je crois pas
finalement ligne bien trop oui beaucoup
oui mais le vôtre est particulier car
oui nos sélections des choses les faits
notre société s'était inscrit société
qu'ils déforment je n'intéresse pas été
dit si je crois pas alors dieu c'est
françoise sagan vous avez raconté des
histoires d'amour dans mon livre
peut-être que l'une des plus belles et
dans cet ouvrage est le héros en est un
cheval qui s'appelle gladiateurs oui bah
oui ce me sens hyper v magnifique
quelques mots quand même plus ma
récompense c'est le chemin qui la statue
qui est à longchamp des chevals super
qu'ils gagnent et tout mais qui ne
voulait absolument pas s'intéresser des
juments et un état non c'est vraiment
important
les petites îles et les gens les plus
belles rien et puis un jour j'ai croisé
dans les chais dans les chemins de
longchamp une vieille jument flapi comme
ça qui traînait rashard aubrée de
feuilles mortes un rôle tout à fait
subalterne
il s'est dressé son départ hier il a
contré tous les signes de la passion
tous les sens dans tous les sens du
terme
on se dit tiens qu'est ce qui se passe
car plus d'entrain tron s'est frotté les
mains pour l'amener pas le jugement
superbe vient de nouveaux seront deux
fois et croit sa jument une seconde fois
et ce dès vie mais l'été gilles à
décider vraiment vous quand je dis pluie
de cartons en gros c'est vrai quoi si la
comparaison est belle et finalement
désigné les propriétaires les gens de
chevaux l'oncle offertes du jugement
élèvent des enfants il faut tout était
merveilleux des six grandes compagnies
quelque peu d'histoire oui c'est le
passé
des textes c'est une lettre d'adieu un
homme aimé c'est aimer puis on se quitte
et c'est une lettre c'est une aide que
vous avez envoyé un homme très
précisément ou bien c'est une lettre je
dirais un peu généraliste avec à la fois
sorte d'exercice de coeur et de style
que j'ai failli envoyer moquetté moyens
décrits fait celui ci avait failli non
oui autant vous l'aviez gardez donc pu
retrouver je me suis dit ce critère est
mal écrit ça fait beaucoup
quel abruti pas parce qu'on dit dans ces
cas là et puis j'ai modifié
est-ce qu'on peut écrire une lettre
d'adieu a un amant est ce que ça peut
être la même chose que un texte qu'on va
qu'on va reproduire dans cette extrême
en changer pour changer ça c'était
l'idée de je vais laisser les cafés les
bistrots des romans avait été il était
assez mal et j'ai pas envoyer des gangs
studio ils doivent rien compris les
déchets de mai l'idée de parler c'est
joli j'ai complètement réécrit ce prix
là dessus nous avez envoyé beaucoup des
lettres d'adieu comme ça non non non je
n'ai pratiquement jamais la preuve j'ai
gardé celle là je disais les adieux de
vie voire la table de leap qui est fait
pour ça ou les boiteux lui oui non à une
table chez lipp à paris on peut faire ce
qu'on veut parce que les gens passent
tout le temps ils disent bonjour les
pires scènes sont arrêtés par ce passage
la tête du coin non peut pas dire adieu
à un homme qu'on a aimé ici quand même
donc pas ici chez lipp hô chi minh en
bio c'est vrai chez lipp on peut le
faire taper quand on n'est pas à bord de
seine oui moi j'avais jamais vu ça quand
je suis intact exposer les gens qui
rentrent et qui sortent pas devant vous
vous disant bonjour et au revoir donc on
ne peut pas laisser ne peuvent pas dire
des trucs mais enfin quand on prend
congé d'un homme il ya des cris et des
pleurs
si on veut les éviter ce qui peut
arriver aussi parce que est ce que une
romancière elle peut pas éviter ces
choses là je trouve sa soeur fortifie
justement il en écrit ainsi avec en plus
un livre ça c'est oui mais c'est parce
qu'elle les vies qu'elle peut en parler
bien pour du tout pas du tout non non
pensez vous si vous demandez pas sans
risque être plus beau dans ce tutoriel
est pas moi pour ça là il ya un texte
aussi sur casar sur le lot sur votre
enfance on aurait aimé qu'il fut plus
long oui mais j'ai pensé que j'étais je
voulais pas trop trop rabattre de gens
leur carte du charme ne s'attendaient
pas à tant qu'il est vide je vieillis
films art et essai fille sage et
spécifie bien que rien à faire il ya
aussi un texte qui est un éloge du rire
et vous dites que vous avez beaucoup ri
dans votre vue dans votre vie que est-ce
que vous vivriez autant qu'il y à bize
en 20 ans 30 ans est-ce que vous riez de
la même manière pour les mêmes choses
pour les mêmes gens je crois que le sens
de l'humour change pas tellement je ris
peut-être de choses
je suis pas du tout en fait je sujet de
rire non pas toi caraty de marche
le verbe est et puis la lorie repêché
pied quand on lit quand on dit qu'il
faut des plus jeunes et pas toujours sur
les mêmes histoires qui vous font rire
aujourd'hui nouvelles et à ce que vous
montez l'insecte c'est que le rire très
important dans l'amour et l'amitié il
peut pas y avoir d'amour et d'amitié
sans rire je crois cela dit quand on est
content les amoureux de quelqu'un on vit
pas on est assez bon et d'angoissé au
début au début et après on rigole
attaquant il est évident que quand même
un peu moins pour bientôt un général à
ses passions on peut rire nos débuts on
rit pas mais est ce que le signe d'une
de la fin d'une liaison d'une rupture ce
n'est pas justement lorsqu'on ne rit
plus ensemble des mêmes choses moi je
trouve
oui l'absence de réattaquer très
inquiétante de même si quelqu'un que
vous aimez riz avec quelqu'un nouveau
faut se méfier
ah oui grand rire comme cervelas mais
deux personnes qui rient ensemble et on
n'est pas dans leur complicité
et si l'année
est ce important pour vous faire très
attention et de même les enfants c'est
souvent une blessure pour les enfants
quand ils voient des adultes qui rit
entre eux et lorsqu'ils sont écartés de
ce ring c'est le sien ce qui est décent
pour les adultes comme aux enfants me
sens oui c'est vrai aussi
alors je vous ai apporté des des
photographies là vous me direz si ces
gens là vous font rire ou pas rire oui
le premier évidemment je sais qui vous
fait rire parce que vous fait son éloge
dans votre livre c'est jacques chazot ah
oui il m'a toujours fait rire challes
pourquoi elle vous fait rire jacques
chaize parce qu'il est désopilant parce
qu'il a visités surtout il est d'un
klaxon rapidité foudroyante faux comptes
en comptant la taxe qui arrive souvent
il serait très drôle j'ai protesté oui
bien sûr extrêmement mou c'est avant
quelqu'un qui m'a fait plus rire avec
louis de funès
ah oui beaucoup oui de gré ou de force
parce que mon fils m'a emmené huit fois
voir oscar
rien ne vaut une mauvaise qualité ce
comique anglais qui est mort il ya
quelques semaines bénigne invités c'est
drôle mais quelques fois il fait une
fois sur deux je trouvais ils étaient
dix au bilan oui il y avait les
chantiers extrait fondeur trop lui
inutile aux chevrons obsédé sexuel ça
doit toujours y courraient toujours
après les dames et dans les ardennes
est ce que monsieur vous a fait beaucoup
rire
vous avez été mariée avec lui s'appelle
guy schüller elle est très drôle dit
madame en février mais parce que
pourquoi tu te fais plus riches et à
bangui oui j'étais j'étais très jeune
j'étais très enfin bref et au début m'a
pas fait rire mais après oui
et maintenant il fait beaucoup plus
qu'avant et celui ci confiance et
bernard blier
oui oui vous ai rien il peut guérir oui
alors là par exemple vous avez enfin
alain rémond là il fait l'éloge de
bernard blier et pourquoi ouais c'est
celui qui m'a toujours fait le plus rien
au cinéma et à côté énorme
chez lui et puis il fait très bien les
focus trop façon de faire comme ça les
petits yeux de mimer de plein de choses
de ne pas dire vraiment ce qu'ils
pensent et la fille bliard fait de lui
avec des dialogues en bouche elles sont
d'une heure il est c'était pour sa
cuisine y est du dialogue la tendance à
nous il est aussi des côtés mur il
détrône roger pailles et puis là c'est
mitterrand grenouille dans le bébête
show ce que ça vous fait rien il a
toujours été très drôle mais voter
mitterrand lui-même sans nom par
grenoble me fais ma fait rire souvent
oui je voulais poser s'il ya beaucoup
mitterrand le vrai millions fait plus
rire que la gac et la grenouille
alors ça c'est ppda en guignols de
l'info voilà je parle de l'ensemble des
guignols de l'info c'est bon mais je
peux pas 400 philippe j'ai fait un
procès aurait fait un procès mais parce
qu'il vous est paru et vous et paris en
plus il m'affiche et sa grande jetée
dans cette affaire et en plus il me
montrait d'une manière déplaisante
déplaisante et fatale fâcheuses donc ça
c'est bien pas rire du tout sur le trou
final on est trop laid on es trop
minable on n'est pas super symbole
ben oui mais regardez cabu lui aussi il
vous transforme ses terres et ben oui
mais c'est pas pareil que d'attendre
tous les mardis quelqu'un qui arrive et
qui réunit bon il celui ci est ce qui
vous fait de vos amis s'appellent
bernard frank banham texte extrêmement
mourir va justement notre g rhône on a
vu une page de jk jérôme ont pleuré un
sondage vous pleuriez ensemble oui en
visant dû inviter jk je fais mes mort
d'un touriste et qui est-ce qui misait
bernard qui essayait drire le lire ne
pouvait pas pleurer tellement dur et
palin moi j'avais eue avant je savais
que c'était j'allais pleurer avant mais
est ce que frédéric dard san-antonio
vous fait rire mais toujours debout
ferrer oui je vais c'est facile
je suis un peu facile de ce côté gérer
également vous êtes bon public très bas
oui très bon public
oui et alors est ce que par exemple du
boulet des saintes du bout je vous
donnais devait aussi concerner bout du
bout que si cuche a en revanche prêté
chez moi par exemple je sais pas est-ce
que kabyles du bouffey ou moi pour moi
c'est un des génies du dessin du 20e
siècle
pour moi c'était vraiment le plus grand
dessinateur français pour pour valence
qui par exemple forme de sait que trop
bien pour moi ce que j'ai dit je
regrette vraiment de ne pas avoir pu
l'inviter parce qu'il refusait toute
télévision
c'est vraiment alors je vous signale à
ce propos l'ouverture d'un musée d'un
musée albert dubout à palavas-les-flots
sais pas c'est pas la ville où il est né
mais il est devenu s'est pris de passion
pour
pour palavas dans une renault du xviiie
siècle qui est élevé sur une île et on y
présentera en permanence 150 dessins et
peintures donc de de dubout et puis
alors maintenant dernier je voulais pas
vous présenter la photo cabu et ce qui a
pu offrir une chance il est là françoise
sagan dans le premier anniversaire de
vous êtes au courant et c'est un grand
honneur de l'avoir parmi nous je vous
laisse pour le premier anniversaire de
journal texte vous n'allez pas le qua
non le thème c'est très dur de gauche la
gauche c'est par où la rouge c'est pas
la gauche c'est par où demande son
chemin à roubaix pour aller à gauche
c'est pas vrai donc pour aller à gauche
c'est pareil c'est ça ah oui ne soyez
pas hors sujet après l'écrivain qui
téléphonent pourquoi êtes vous
pourquoi deux bouts de gauche va prêter
à prendre vous pouvez voter c'est pour
circuler les états généraux du parti
socialiste vous mettez dans ses mauvais
kalou fait engueuler par mitterrand non
pas du tout bon très bien alors quel but
qu'est ce que vous allez faire au japon
enfin je vous imagine pas l'auteur du
grand duduche et du beauf et au japon
mais quitte ou mon dieu et justement il
ya des beaufs partout vous savez est ce
qu'il ya des beaufs japonais oui on les
appelle les yakuzas c'est les gangsters
mais non je suis allé voir les
japonaises ce qui est mieux dans ce pays
là tout le reste on peut s'en passer
encore que j'espère qu'ils vont ils vont
arriver à changer les choses peut-être
parce qu'ils sont ils sont ils ont ils
auraient la technique pour pour vivre
moins bêtement quoi il sait des écolos
quand même quand ils comptent ils
veulent quand quand il trouve le moyen
de rap de gagner du fric avec vous êtes
deux parties à deux et vous pour le les
textes veut rapportés de voyage à pau
vous êtes pressé combien de temps je
suis allé deux fois trois semaines à wil
pas mal
donc vous avez nord et sud voyez à
partir de tokyo je vais fait des croquis
des choses vu des choses noté des
esquisses des personnages des portraits
et puis à côté court tout le long du
bouquin un test qui est lui est très
sérieux jean-christophe tournebize il
est là et oui et on apprend beaucoup de
choses d'ailleurs c'est très intéressant
parce que il ya des points de vue sur
l'économie sur la société japonaise sur
est alors voilà donc c'est ce mélange
grand spécialiste de là
il a fait un livre sur le le tibet est
un livre sur la chine et il connaît
aussi parfaitement le chapon puisqu'il
travaille comme journaliste je crois
qu'on peut le dire à la fp et cabu vous
dites un moment ça c'est votre sous
votre signature
constat edith cresson avait raison oui
c'est vrai ils vivent comme des fourmis
enfin ils vivent dans des clapiers vivre
comme des dingues
il ya un fourmillement là-bas
extraordinaire c'est vrai elle avait
raison c'est pour ça qu'il lui en
veulent beaucoup d'ailleurs parce qu'il
croit toujours qu'elle est premier
ministre d'ailleurs jean pas suivi le
changement oui oui ils disent mais
pourquoi vous supportez les femmes
pareil qui est un dragon et et vous
ajoutez que c'est vrai que 626 millions
de français vivaient sur un tiers de
notre territoire français par ces sacs
japon oui alors qu'est ce qu'il se
battrait tous tous les françaises
battrait c'est parce qu'ils ont une
éducation aussi aussi aussi raffiné
aussi soucie beaucoup de l'autre quoi
qu'il arrive à tenir sur un petit espace
comme ça mais c'est surtout la culture
mme kim qui m'a plu quand même parce que
préféreraient vivre au japon qu'aux
états unis par exemple voyez à cause de
la culture parce que même s'ils ont
l'air américanisé c'est superficiel et
on voit partout des des tas de belles
choses c'est à dire les petites choses
c'est récents très joli mais
les villes où les l'urbanisme par
exemple c'est monstrueux très très très
long parce qu'il n'y a pas de plan
d'occupation des sols oui tout est
construit anarchiquement il monte e
place oui c'est vrai c'est vrai oui oui
mais en même temps tournebize et vous
vous dites leurs trains arrivent à
l'heure c'est toujours réglé c'est
parfait ya pas de retard jamais tout
marche
ah ouais alors à sa sinistre mais à quel
prix nous on prend un train qui arrive
avec un d'ordre un quart d'heure de
retard ont tout le monde gueule c'est
vrai que c'était un service payé un peu
ennuyé à force alors sam karmann vous
revenez du japon et dont il faut dire
que vous étiez avec la délégation
française du cinéma voilà premier
festival à yokohama s'est lui présenté
les films français aux japonais oui on
se demande mais c'est un succès oui quel
est le film qui a été présenté c'est le
les films qui ont été présents viennent
aux normes élevées grands films comiques
lac et obtient beaucoup de 17h des
visiteurs et ils ont ri aux visiteurs ou
pas ils ont ri aux visiteurs ouais ouais
mais je joue parce que les visiteurs se
pressaient plus un film comique une
comédie c'est plutôt c'est burlesque et
donc de julien ça ne c'est
compréhensible même sans sous titres ou
les comédies les comédies c'est plus
difficile les comédies de textes sont
plus difficiles votre machine
je trouve pardon votre film a été
présenté là-bas le camp merde oui oui ça
a fonctionné parce que là aussi je crois
que c'est pas c'est pas une question
peut-être c'est une question de
situation qui fonctionne mais je trouve
le bouquin je vraiment je suis tombé de
rire la première phase est né pendant ce
temps là les japonais dorment il faut
savoir que c'est frais c'est dire que le
bouquin de cabu formidable et il est
encore plus formidable quand on en
reviens parce que c'est vrai mes talibés
ce qui met tout dans son livre est vrai
aidé à remonter le temps et donc tout
donner dès qu'ils ont deux minutes
comment on dit nous parlant les japonais
travaillent mais oui sauf sauf quand ils
prennent le train sauf quand ils
prennent le bus sauf parfois quand même
compter une marche se demander si une
banque d'un quand il marche mais parce
qu'ils ont deux heures couramment de
transport enfin à peu râler pour revenir
donc ils dorment dans les trains il
s'était dit vous savez que le soir ils
rentrent chez eux parce qu'ils ont des
dîners d'affaires avec les représentants
et tout ça ils rentrent pas avant
je pas quelle heure est complètement
bourré et le lendemain il se lève comme
ça à gars c'est vrai on les voit alors
la journée ils dorment où ils peuvent
non non ça dure huit minutes j'avais de
la chance c'est le film que vous verrez
tout à l'heure et dure huit minutes
seulement gagné une chose quand même
qu'il y est j'ai trouvé tragique c'est
vrai qu'on veut on ne voit pas de trace
de manoeuvre au japon mais on ne voit
pas de traces de bonheur
on ne voit on voit une machine une
mécanique implacable impeccable les
fameux wii japonaises malgré ce qu'on
ait pièce est vrai j'ai été parce que
leurs maris sont gênés là ils sont gênés
là je souhaite aux noms mettons pas en
personne n'a intérêt à propos des femmes
cabu dit ceci on comprend que ce vieux
cochant d'ennery millaire soit mort dans
les bras d'une japonaise
ah oui oui je crois que les français
sont attirés par les japonais c'est vrai
vous étiez attirés par ce qu'elles sont
très belles ce que j'étais que mon frère
pas sûr tant le l'avait beaucoup
ils ont tellement tonnes de savon
[Rires]
et je m'aperçois vous fumez plus si je
ne suis pas timide alors c'est pas une
incitation à fumer mais d'un seul coup
je me tiens mais pas ce que je faisais
toujours vu un peu ce train de fumer
fumée fumée et là je me dis c'est pas
tout à l'heure c'est seulement alors et
la côte des français au japon les côtes
des français célèbrent les noms et les
machos les français s'en sont pris pour
des machos alors que les japonais sont
plus macho non on n'a pas tellement de
succès non non ce qui plaît c'est
toujours le parfum les bêtises quoi il
nous oblige pas le départ de long et à
huy les nuances qui marche mieux c'est
il s'appelle marceau sophie marceau oui
parce que peut-être qu'elle avait un
film avec une belle petite a présenté
ses ça marche et c'est bien belle petite
actrice a présenté en fait une belle
actrice petit ou grand déjà fait en mars
aux etats unis
non mais je ne parle pas de ce fait mal
je parle pour les actrices à venir
d'accord il ya un créneau
il faut pas croire que mireille mathieu
s'est fini c'est une légende
mais curieusement joe dassin ça marche
encore oui
et bien un buffet ah oui bon il amusé là
bas c'est à dire que c'est à l'intérieur
d'un grand magasin comme tout se passe
dans les grands magasins
les musées sont appartiennent à des
clubs et françoise sagan oui je viens
classicisme un clown on voit des des
traductions
oui il est clair qu'il y avait un club
comme l avenir et michael impériale
comme françois sabouret qu'est-ce qu'ils
font exprès que je n'ai pas trop perdu
de sa famille d'accueil
mais j'ai vu quelque part que vous
disiez que pour eux
vous représentez la liberté oui pour des
japonaises on peut venir me voir quand
j'étais là-bas en geignant que la veine
beach vous êtes allé au japon
ah oui donc vous allez voir votre femme
club j'ai patiné dans mon fan club j'ai
vu plein de chaponnay japonais pas
japonais c'est très très mélancolique
tout à fait piéger mais une conférence
est alors et les bons le câble cabillaud
japon ça vous a plu beaucoup mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya une page magnifique
le japon est une secte qui produit qui
produisent marchandises pour le monde
entier c'est ça ça c'est magnifique
c'est assez mais c'est ça pour le peu
que j'en ai vu mais c'est formidable
bouquin parce qu'il est chronologique
c'est que j'étais totalement je suivais
totalement jusqu'à la 25e page mais
comme je suis resté qu'une semaine ça
s'est arrêté je sûr que six semaines je
moi ce que je trouve rigolo dans son
livre c'est le texte est très très
pondéré très bien très très bien écrit
avec des belles périodes un très beau
ch'ti puis au milieu de tout ça il ya
les espèces de dessin banzaï l'avait
kamikaze ii de cabu ça fait un effet
totalement d'étonnant c'est une cruauté
c'est le formulaire moi je me suis
régalé mais le la balance entre le texte
et l'image ça fait ça fait un cocktail
molotov qui est étonnant alors c'est une
idée de jean claude guillebaud le
directeur de collection qui veut des
alors je reste comme ça j'ai oublié de
dire que cabu au japon ça sort aux
éditions du seuil
et puis vous avez un autre livre
s'intitule responsable mais pas coupable
l'écho des savanes albin michel
il vous a plu
dire cela ce gars est féroce on peux
nous présenter tout de suite quelques
dessins ça c'est absolument féroce aux
armes alors la propre au delà du sang
contaminé
on va voir je sais pas garreta par
exemple voilà garreta pour vient
chauffer le sens des voeux sur les
tombes
qu'est ce qu'on peut nous montrer après
voilà c'est terrifiant mais mais là il
s'en prend quand même beaucoup à la
gauche qui était au pouvoir
évidemment il ya le décalage des livres
ça vous gêne pas françoise sagan ça vous
ennuie pas sans même que bérégovoy que
des présents dans cet ouvrage j'ai pas
revu mais oui oui ça il est présentement
à oui oui ça c'est sûr il est même en
couverture j'aurais dû le mettre là plus
grands noms et verrez qu'on voit c'est
vrai il lui manque d'humour je pense
pour faire ça on ne peut pas manquer
d'humour non on jouait tous courage et
de fausses nouvelles
je crois qu'il faut être encouragée
penser qu est-ce qu on peut le montrer
d'autres desseins s'il vous plaît voilà
voilà
c'est l'alliance avant de l'acheter way
alors oui il y en a vraiment qui sont
terribles et ja j'ai fait ça avant il ya
là d'une férocité qui rappelle
l'assiette au beurre
je crois qu'un dessinateur sont alors
sujets d'actualité les intermittents du
spectacle l'ancien dauphin de johnny les
anciennes épouses de barclays ah oui
vous savez on est content d'être là
plutôt que au stade
1 à la fête de johnny hallyday ce soir
des princes beaucoup de gens les
skinheads d'ailleurs d'emmanuelle béart
qui adorent et johnny hallyday
voilà on va justement on va parler de la
télévision et avant de parler de
télévision je vous propose françoise
sagan de revoir un document fabuleux
c'est le début d'une interview que vous
avez accordé à pierre desproges en 1975
pour le petit rapporteur de jacques
martin à une époque j'aurais de ladite
suite ou des proches n'étaient pas du
tout connu
donc le petit rapporteur françoise sagan
comment ça va le petit santé de bain
très bien merci
ça va très bien combien j'allais bien
oui oui ça va très bien qu'il n'ya pas
de problème nous ne nous alléger même
commune tout paris mais non qu'est ce
que je veux dire
la règle assez bien
c'est pas mal comme tissu ça c'est quoi
au style mélange de deux toiles flanelle
de draps je passe le jeu prend sa
peluche pas sauf que non non ce ne se
pose pas ce tissu assez sec ça se lavent
commencent à se lave à l'eau tiède et
biens de secours savent plus tôt c'est
peu de chose combien chez le teinturier
ah bon ouais ouais on peut pas de toute
façon vous n'avez pas le temps moi aussi
quand je n'ai pas le temps je donne des
trucs passionnants nature y est oui non
franchement sera toujours faire des
lessives
c'est vrai et les vacances c'était bien
vos vacances vous étiez en vacances le
chapeau à nos lâchetés pas en vacances
ce travail et non mais avant j'avais
l'avantagé de travailler c'est en
vacances en france
forcément oui mais c'était il a facile
il a fait très beau c'est du beau temps
ci oui moi je suis allé chercher mon
beau-frère que près de limoges joaillier
ah oui je connais bien c'est toujours de
l'humour et sa bande ça descend c'est le
choix qui est 17e et les champignons là
sa maman en ce moment c'est bien une
champignons et moi aussi bien marrer
quand vous faire que la joue entre et
des photos les zélateurs cd photos qu'on
a fait avec rajouté en vacances ou ont
beau frère ces mois-là l'on se lâche
alain pendant un chien là c'est pas vous
ce poste un chien là ah oui c'est mon
chien ça à ma part goris prochain c'est
bon ça c'est un copain pendant vos
frères cette saison au printemps il sa
petite touche à souhait
bon et c'est une incroyable combien nous
oui mais là vous êtes bien d'une
gentillesse jusqu'au bout
ce n'est pas très bon je misais le
pauvre garçon qu'est ce qu'on peut
voyager pas quoi faire pour lui je ne le
connaissais pas il était là il reste bof
revolver dû écouter c'est pas
intéressant
il ya pas un méchant je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai pas fait chaud très
longtemps c'est tout
oui c'est beau frère maintenant tant pis
c'est pas le choix
mais ces canons mais c'est un document
étonnant ah non pas du tout ah non pas
du tout contre vous êtes tellement à non
absolument pas il va être complètement
il est complètement le garçon ait étoile
après il est devenu de thèmes très très
célèbre je crois dans sa tête il
respirait il voulait je chasse qui vous
est cher oui oui mais oui mais justement
vous vous êtes d'une patience infinie
pas du tout après vous demande
d'ailleurs d'une tisane pourquoi
c'était quand même un document alors oui
dans votre livre est un délit un texte
sur la télévision c'est le démontage
d'un débat et c'est vrai alors là quand
on lit ce texte on est effectivement
tous les débats se ressemble à celui que
vous racontez un petit peu inventé les
personnages sont désactivés mon vrai les
types qui se présente au nom du public
qu'il faut ce que m'ont dit les
fonctions publiques qui vous regardent à
penser aux français ce qu'ils vont
penser de vous qu'il ya toujours un
risque
et puis à celui ci traite tout le monde
qui ne seraient pas venues
oui il ya le meneur de jeu bon
évidemment il ya la victime il ya
toujours une pauvre victime il ya le
provocateur il ya le ce que vous appelez
le bonus c'est quoi le bonheur on est
d'accord ou pas tourné d'accord
finalement fait il penser au foot dans
sa fiche tout le débat par terre il ya
le représentant du représentant du
public
alors il ya le délégué communisme est de
moins en moins facile est toujours là
mais numéro très simple tu as très sec
qui déroule après la montre et demi
l'érudit etc bref celui que j'aime bien
c'est le campagnard est très bien il a
son numéro de campagn'art très rodée il
y jamais à la campagne millambourg
côtelé et joue le rôle des campagnes et
des martyrs sur sa pire il a le rôle du
campagnol à la raymond vous êtes le
critique de télérama depuis combien
d'années 13 ans je crois vous en avez
pas marre de regarder la télé soit pour
faire des papiers ne remet pas cher dans
la plaie si vous voulez me décourager
encore non oui à l'essor où j'en ai
marre c'est sûr ça dépend quel soir là
ce soir ça va comme suit pas dans mon
post oui mais alors en même temps c'est
vrai et c'est pas vrai parce que donc
vous publié sous le titre les mémoires
de mon oeil et mon oeil c'est le titre
de votre chronique d'un été rama aux
éditions du seuil
un choix de vos chroniques de télévision
depuis du son les trois ou quatre
dernières années à peu près et quand on
lit ça on s'aperçoit vous rigolez
beaucoup vous vous amusez beaucoup
heureusement parce que c'est déjà assez
dur faut dire ce qui est de regarder la
télé tous les soirs alors si on peut pas
rigoler si on va pas en rire un peu
quand on quand on l'écrit surtout si peu
à peu la peine de continuer mais enfin
je suis pas totalement masochistes quand
même c'est vrai que j'aime bien la
télévision sans sage j'arrêterai
d epuis à les choses que j'aime bien
aussi à la télévision il ya des missions
que j'aime bien quand même
il ya tellement de choses nulles que
plutôt que de monter sur ses grands
chevaux et faire des grands numéros
d'indignation j'ai trouvé que c'était
mieux de rigoler un peu d'en rire un peu
oui et en même temps heureusement pour
vous qui a des émissions vulgaire nul
raté et c'est pas autrement
c'est toujours en train de faire des
papiers sérieux sur des éliminations
intelligente par exemple j'ai pas la
marche du siècle et autres et là c'est
votre chronique deviendrait très envie
bah oui c'est un effet pervers
d'ailleurs dès fois de ce que j'écris
ces quelques enjeux raconte des
émissions à c nul mais où je ris man ray
a beau temps les gens me disent le
lendemain c'est dommage j'aurais dû la
regarder mais je la regarderai la
prochaine j'ai l'effet inverse de ce que
je vais penser ça quand on en n'est pas
là uniquement d émission passionnante
oui alors évidemment vous raconter ça
dans un style qui est bien à vous c'est
à dire à vous prenez des colères de
temps en temps c'est le pouce et des
colères quand vous êtes curieux mais
quand même la plupart du temps vous vous
en amuser oui j'essaye j'essaie de ce
pique des colères quand ça quand ça ne
mérite
puis je pique aussi des colères pour des
choses dérisoires mais qui intéresse
beaucoup de critiques de télévision
c'est quand l'intérêt ne marche pas au
vin et aux scop est en panne ou leur âge
est tombé sur l'antenne mais ça marche
puis voilà ça c'est où l' envie de jeter
le poste par la fenêtre parce que c'est
vraiment vraiment trop nul il ya
quelques morceaux qui mérite vraiment le
détour il ya notamment l'interview de
fidel castro par jean edern hallier
il y a le philippe sollers chez
dechavanne
c'était dans ciel mon mardi dans l'air
c'est quelqu'un que j'adore voir la
télévision j'aime beaucoup vers le
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'écrivains
utilisions sollers on a l'impression
qu'on peut le lancer sur n'importe quel
sujet mais on met une pièce dans le dans
la machine ça y est ça démarre on entend
presque les cliquetis de la mécanique
qui se met en route broadseis est parti
on lance sur n'importe quoi moi je me
lasse pas de le regarder il ya beaucoup
de gens comme ça la visite de léon
zitrone chez la princesse marie
christine de 15 ou lui fait un numéro de
charme extraordinaire il la drague a
failli à la maison qu'il a fait
l'émission pour ça pour y faire la fin
une déclaration d'amour
il va il va aussi amoureux données chez
des il va l'accompagner chez des petits
des petites personnes qui sont qui sont
sourdes c'est les oeuvres de charité de
la scène brave cette brave comtesse ou
duchesse alors elle dit quelques mots et
et on l'entend lyon qui dit ah j'ai
l'impression qu'ils nous entendent pas
beaucoup évidemment ils sont souvent il
est perspicace et et puis il ya aussi
une chronique étonnante où on découvre
que le grand cuisinier bernard loiseau
et en direct dans deux émissions sur
deux chaînes différentes
là j'ai cru que je devenais fou parce
que il arrive de zapper d'une mission à
l'autre et il est effectivement dans
2005 censées être en direct
il est et en même temps dans les deux
emissions alors là c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient moment se demande je est un
autre qui disait rimbaud et puis alors
il ya un morceau étonnant c'est le
passage de françoise sagan à caractère
avec petter sommes que oui ça leur fasse
ça j'avoue que ça allait bien fait rire
exactement parce qu'il était le sujet
vous racontiez armand secret des faux
fuyants et vous disiez que en l'écrivant
vous ayez demander si on riait à chaque
fois et vous aviez quelqu'un à côté de
vous et vous disiez des phrases et si la
personne à côté de vous riez vous vous
continuez alors c'était vous avez
raconté sales ondemand et peter handke
vu ça la fait pas rire du tout et il
avait dit c'est complètement idiot on
n'écrit pas un roman les cédantes faire
rire séduit vous avez complètement
écrabouillé je me souviens vous étiez là
comme ça ben c'est bien la dernière fois
j'essaye de faire revenir senti humilié
est ce que j'avais vous été embêté qui
n'ont pas du tout trouvé c'est cocasse
puisque il était déchaîné et c'était pas
tellement important juge ni gêner on
équilibre doit pas faire rire peut-être
un peu doctrinal quoi ce que j'avais
trouvé très votre nom c'est qu'après lui
même a dû raconter son livre et ils
avaient beaucoup de mal à raconter et
c'est vous qui l'avaient aidée il ya les
idents du lama et c'était très bien vous
étiez pas rancunière non c'était en fait
c'était une vengeance affreuse parce que
dira rien de pire finalement que de
douleur de vous dire quelqu'un qui a
pris vie y est c'est extrêmement n'ont
souhaité vous protéger mais d'autres
soucis
oui est ce qu est ce que vous pourriez
devenir par exemple comme daniel
schneidermann dans le monde critique
quotidien la télévision je l'envié joli
ça sa chronique tous les jours j'ai
l'impression qu'on ne peut plus faire
que ça et penser qu'à ça dégèle mondiale
a besoin que j'y passe beaucoup de temps
dans l'univers de la télévision qu est
un univers un peu curieux ou et obsédant
et quand on fait ça tous les jours
se demande combien de temps il va tenir
avant le disons parce que c'est vrai que
c'est vraiment dur quoi non je ne crois
pas que sincèrement je trouve très bien
de rythme hebdomadaire
je me fais mes petits programmes chaque
semaine je suis ma petite tambouille
dans mon coin
la petite cuisine et puis j'écris
tranquillement reste que les directeurs
de chaîne les producteurs les animateurs
proteste quand vous voulez ça arrive
oui oui j'ai quelques quelques coups de
figer des lettres d'insultés sublime ça
mais ça m'est arrivé que ce garde parce
que très belle très bien écrite j'ai des
coups de téléphone de deux réalisateurs
ou producteurs qui menace de procès est
fou furieux enfin bon mais de moins en
moins parce que je crois qu'ils ont ils
ont compris un peu la règle du jeu
et puis bon je crois que c'est un peu
normal finalement c'est le roi de la
critique
qu'est ce que vous aimez la télévision
oui et mais ce que je quand on pose
cette question j'ai envie à chaque pas
te demander mais est ce que la
télévision même mois parce que parce que
chineurs et puis qu'est ce qu'elle aime
en moi parce que j'ai l'impression de la
télévision se fait une image pas
seulement de moi mais les
téléspectateurs comme des beaufs ou des
idées ou des abrutis et m en nous ce qui
a moins aimables de plus bête et donc
moi j'ai un peu l'impression que je fais
un peu de
j'ai envie qu'on m'aime pour autre chose
que la télévision un moment autre chose
que ne cultive pas assez cela dit bien
sûr j'aime la télé sans ça je vous dis
je suis pas complètement masochiste donc
je laime quand même j'aime les images
surtout j'aime beaucoup beaucoup d
images et c'est d'ailleurs ce que je
reproche souvent à la télévision c'est
que la télé n'aime pas assez les images
ne fait pas assez confiance aux images
n'a passé d'imagination il n'y a pas de
vraie culture de l'image à la télévision
c'est quelque chose que je trouve date
assez désolant comment elle massacre
elle même le seul massacre et même la
télé comment elle n'a pas le goût des
images mais en même temps pour dire ça
vous êtes obligé de parler
ben oui exactement mais je le dis en
parlant mais je dis aussi en écrivant
oui nous servait toujours de maux oui
puisque les images n'ai pas de mots il
ya le
les images c'est des images avec dix
sont quand même c'est les images et les
races toutes seules savent où je sais
pas si vous vous rappelez pour la 500e
ou six centième émission d' apostrophes
j'avais fait une fausse apostrophe pour
la télévision commerciale et où il y
avait d'ailleurs solaire s'il y avait
claude aron distribués à la fin des dix
tribus est le plus beau des cocottes
minutes ou les réfrigérateurs etc
alors aujourd'hui je vous propose une
version moderne de bouillon de culture
un bouillon de culture vraiment à la
mode d'aujourd'hui que qui s'intitule
culture le cul
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous merci pour cet accueil si
chaleureux et surtout merci pour tous
ces applaudissements
ma première invitée c'est l'excellente
romancière irène frain
et mon second invité c'est le grand
comédien chaque françois
irène ça va très bien et jacques
françois ça va aussi mal
et bien je vous invite à vous asseoir
irène pourquoi avez vous choisi le
métier d'écrire parce que c'est cool
j'hallucine quand j'écris s'est montré
leur maîtrise et c'est cool c'est ça
m'éclate sécu et jacques françois
pourquoi avez vous choisi ce métier là
comique dicks au théâtre au cinéma par
paresse j'étais convaincu que au théâtre
au cinéma on devenait célèbre très vite
ont gagné des milliards
en effet tant absolument rien je crois
que se livrent des vies que vous avez
romans documents que vous avez publié
quelques mois je crois très sincèrement
que c'est votre meilleur lire absolument
couple est très très loin son meilleur
lait alors je dois dire que je les ai
relu l'avant de m'aider à faire cette
émission et toutes les pages sont
excellentes mais il ya vraiment utile
faudrait que je la retrouve
voilà c'est la pâle la pâte 183 c'est
une page sublime
voilà trois je trouve pas mal mais je
trouve que ça n'a aucun rapport avec la
page 228 qu'il a vraiment c'est
fantastique
enfin c
jacques françois votre meilleur film
enfin tout cas pour moi c'est
incontestablement les trois
mousquetaires d'andré hunebelle vote a
très bien fait je suis pas d'accord pour
les trois mousquetaires vous préférez un
autre film les grandes manoeuvres
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai pas vu les
trois mousquetaires ça tombe bien nous
allons nous faire plaisir
nous allons vous admirez dans les trois
mousquetaires dans une belle et jacques
françois vous y jouez le rôle vous
rappelez d'aramis important si vous
aviez cette somme qu'en feriez-vous
j'organiserai un repas mémorables
ne vaudrait-il pas mieux penser aux
nourritures spirituelles - j'engagerai
un valet
vanitas vanitatum et omnia vanitas
faut dire que dans cette citation latine
à la fin vous êtes vraiment bien et vous
méritez ses applaudissements je vous
propose à tous les deux d'élever un peu
le débat je vous propose cette admirable
pensées de pascal personne ne parle en
notre présence comme il parle en notre
absence l'union qui est entre les hommes
n'est fondée que sur cette mutuelle
tromperie la c2 pascal avons nous une
chance de vous applaudir la rentrée
jacques françois de d'applaudir je ne
sais pas moi dans une chance de me voir
dans une pièce de jean louis bourdon une
nouvelle pièce qui s'appelle le landau
qui fait du bruit que d'en créer à la
criée chez maréchal et ensuite à paris
eh bien on vous applaudit doré nectar
et nous terminons cette émission bien
entendu par les questions rituelles
irène frain quel est votre mot préféré
nil merci vous que vous détestez ou père
est patent peut-être merci à tous les
deux merci d'avoir été d'avoir bien
voulu accepter d'être mes invités je
crois que ça a été deux invités par
thuram en brillant et vous méritez ses
applaudissements qu'on ne va pas vous
mélangez
[Musique]
bon bah là aussi
tombé dans le piège exactement alors je
vous signale jacques françois qui a joué
dans les messieurs il a publié des
souvenirs il n'y a pas si longtemps il
rappelle qu' c'est un livre tout à fait
et l'amusant plein et puis on peut si
vous voulez le revoir dans les trois
mousquetaires dans une belle vous pouvez
vous procurer évidemment la caisse est
oui mais vous savez que finalement et je
m'aperçus c'est pas mal hein d'arrivée
sous les applaudissements je trouvais ça
très stimulant fait quelques changements
vous avez encore rien dit on vous
acclament ce formidable il y en a à part
ça les autres continuent et on les voit
pas là et est ce que vous aimeriez
arrivé comme ça maintenant pour les
applaudissements
certains de chine parce que jésus aurait
aimé vous faire et puis et puis à billes
avec des jeunes qui applaudissent on a
une assemblée un peu plus âgées ce qui a
trait forman ans ce sont les pubs on
applaudit ce parce que vous avez ça et
est et où il ya des rires préenregistrés
maintenant je crois qu'avec des rires
préenregistrés seulement dans les
émissions de variétés comme tout le
temps
maintenant il ya même dans les pubs ce
qu'il dit est totalement nulle il ya des
rires préenregistrés
tu as beau monde je nie madness qu en
angleterre il ya aussi des émissions
avec beaucoup de rires
d'applaudissements de général quand il
s'agit de parti conservateur rick et
j'aurai beaucoup mais non en fait cyril
roger ça existe depuis longtemps banni
il le faisait partie de mon éducation
musicale j'ai entendu le monde très
attendu j'ai appris quelque chose en
regardant que ses émissions il est
devenu très connu dans tous les pays du
monde sauf en angleterre
en fait dit rice et bâtiments deux axes
interdits en angleterre vers la fin
parce que pour le public
ces émissions étaient existe mais pour
moi que gain qui courent après des
chutes comme ça c'est ça fait rire mais
ça ne fait pas longtemps que les hommes
politiques menées les politiciens
justement qui gérait la télévision
trouvé que ce n'était pas comme il faut
2006 alors mireille pourquoi votre mari
emmanuel berl écrivains intellectuels
dès 1954 y aura bientôt 40 ans je
l'espère à bientôt 40 ans et donc au
début de la télévision il va quoi pas
beaucoup de postes de télévision
pourquoi s'est-il intéressé la
télévision au point de faire une
critique de cette même télévision dans
la nouvelle revue française
pourquoi parce que j'ai imposé la
télévision chez moi j'ai acheté une
télévision et je l'est parce qu'ils n'en
voulaient pas naturellement
et puis je me suis aperçu que petit à
petit tout l'intéressait il est à lire p
un jour je suis revenu je ramenais dit
fier conservatoire qu'est ce que tu
penses de dutronc dutronc tu ne connais
pas du tronc et tout comme ça la chanson
de johnny hallyday tous il savait tout
tout sur la télé mieux rêver ça
l'amusait ça n'intéresse l intrigue est
et puis voilà je
j'essayais de le faire chanter mais ça
n'a pas marché mais ce que je remarque
c'est qu'il a pris tout de suite la
télévision au sérieux alors qu'à
l'époque du jour appelle les
intellectuels disait c'est rien c'est
nul mais tellement sérieux que entre me
regarder tous un jour je suis revenu et
puis je les trouvais dans la cuisine
dans un état effroyable en train de
faire un tous les cocottes parce qu'il
avait mis vraiment l'hiver à la
télévision faire le poulet cocotte et
qu'il voulait me faire une surprise et
enfin c'était un vrai désastre
mais regardez tout il fallait tout c'est
vrai est ce que je peux lire une petite
chose les le rapport entre lui et moi
j'étais très près de lui un jour
et puis je suis devenu pâle très pâle
alors il a eu peur et machecoul et mais
qu'est ce que tu as et gély je suis en
train de réfléchir à quoi il a répondu
arrête ça tout de suite
ah oui c'est comme ça vous rapport oui
enfin c'est malheureusement que 40 ans
alors l'éditeur françois bourin publié
des recueils de chroniques de télé de
1954 en 1971 d'emmanuel berl présenté
par bernard morlino sous le titre un
téléspectateur engagé et alors ce qui
est vrai c'est que vous venez de dire il
s'intéresse à tourves adrien ses
chroniques au jour de télévision mais
aux émissions de variétés évidemment aux
dramatiques
enfin bref où est ce qu'on appelle ce
qu'on n'appelait pas encore les
téléfilms etc
et c'est vrai que par exemple johnny
hallyday contrairement à kaboul qui ne
m'aiment pas johnny hallyday il est
absolument fasciné par des nervis d
impressionner et terrible je me suis
fait aussi la housse pilier parce que je
ne connaissais pas bien johnny hallyday
12h03 non mais moi je pensais que je
pensais qu'au contraire c'est vous qui
l'aviez initie un à johnny hallyday à la
chanson c'est lui qui critiquait qu'il
n'était pas content parce que je ne
connaissais pas assez bien les chansons
il savait tout d'ailleurs
après je françoise hardy monnaie le
garder quand j'allais au petit
conservatoire
il savait tout sur la chanson j'avais
toujours tous est-ce qu'il ya quelque
chose qui ne savait pas mais ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu'il ait pu imposer
enfin je sais pas imposer tout le monde
était trop fort mais à la nouvelle revue
française qui est quand même une robe
une revue extraordinaire ça y est c'est
pas franchement une rubrique soit la
télévision alors contrairement à tous
les autres il il a vu que ce serait
quelque chose de très important il
acquise a compris il a compris tout sud
est d'angers de télévision aussi tout de
suite alors par exemple danger pour les
écrivains
il a compris de suite avec les écrivains
il allait devoir faire peur il allait
devoir pas seulement savoir écrire mais
aussi savoir mais oui c'est ne voulait
pas jamais face à l'ennui n allait pas
une c'est dérangeait pas d'abord il
était toujours couchée l'écrivez couché
dans sa chambre
mais regardez sa télévision tout le
temps j'avais tout tout tout tout tout
ce que je ne savais pas - je regardais
je voulais le faire chanter
seulement il chantait faux alors vous
avez fait tellement le chantait
tellement de gens c'est pas la peine de
faire chanter votre mari en plus quand
même un peu oui
alors ce qui est vrai aussi c'est que
c'est pas du tout à d'intellectuels
sectaire à la raymond est extraordinaire
il appuie on peut pas vraiment savoir
quels sont ces il n'y a pas de grille
quoi préétabli et c'est vrai que je vous
parle du désert sur johnny hallyday
j'ai été épaté par cette espèce de deux
champs pour johnny vidéo il le compare à
dionysos enfin c est extraordinaire et
ça c'est date de 60 3 ou 4 je crois
enfin c'est hallucinant moi ce qui me
fera beaucoup dansé dansé dans cette
chronique et pour notre métier à nous ça
nous pose une sacrée question c'est
qu'on a l'impression que la période de
pendant laquelle il écrivait c'était
pour nous l'âge d'or de la télévision
les années 60 et lui n'arrête pas de
dire le niveau baisse ni mauvaise et il
commence toutes les chroniques marre ça
y est on est encore descendu plus bas
cette semaine
alors si renée aujourd'hui l'émission
que vous venez
montrez là le prouver sa valeur total
manga vous pouvez même pas imaginer ça
et alors nous on n'arrête pas de dire
aussi le niveau baisse mais jusqu'où on
va descendre mais en fait c'était une
fausse idée qu'on ait deux ego a baissé
sur certaines choses mais il appelle à
grimper l'information c'est évident que
l'information est quand même avec un
rapport avec ce qu'il voyait à l'époque
quand même oui vous a singulièrement
montée mais je me demande si c'est une
question pour nous aussi est-ce qu'on
n'a pas tendance à dire trop trop
facilement le new york post
alors ce qui est vrai aussi c'est que
l'intellectuel qu'il est il n'est pas du
tout pour une des chaînes enfin il ya
une chaîne à l'époque pour une chaîne de
culturel il dit ceci je suis pour
intervilles de guy lux et non pas contre
mais je suis persuadé que shakespeare et
corneille peuvent plaire aux français
non moins que guy lux il est pur biais
luxe mais il est à côté pour molière ou
pour d'autres émissions
il aime les chaînes équilibré il dit il
a une définition d'ailleurs de la
culture la télévision il dit c'est une
émission belle et réussie qu'elle soit
de variété dans le jeu c'est une belle
émission réussie
il veut surtout pas le la culture à caen
grandin sais pas et je crois pour et
allusion à cette phrase je crois bien
que je préfère un palmarès des chansons
un intervilles authentique 1 me teins
montesquiou un shakespeare frelaté mais
je ne me résigne pas à ce choix
le public n'est pas si bête que ces
messieurs se sont mis en tête avait été
qu il a commencé une discussion une
polémique qui n'a cessé ensuite et non
mais c'est ce livre est absolument
souvent passionnants et vous vous disiez
qu'il avait bien vu les dangers
de la dérision c'est vrai pour les
écrivains et de 10 pour la politique ou
si il s'interroge longuement parce qu'il
a vu tous les to les face à face de la
campagne électorale de 1965 qui la
raconte très bien il voit très bien
il a cette phrase sous mitterrand
d'ailleurs qui est assez étonnant si cet
homme qui est sincère en gros plan à la
télévision il n'a plus vers sincère
pourquoi il les développe toute une
théorie sur la politique et la
télévision
il vit aussi il a très bien vu les
dangers de la concurrence des chaînes
mais avec deux chaînes a abandonné oui
on parle on parle d'une troisième chaîne
et il dit je suis sûre que la
concurrence négligera pas la différence
mais tout le contraire hier que
plusieurs à thiennes plus on fera tous
la même chose il avait il écrit très
bien fait que notre religion
bourré d'humour j'ai déjà une fois avec
lui je n'aurais pas été très amusant
oui oui vous n'aviez pas parler de la
télévision n'ont pas du tout fait pour
être sûrement qui vient c'est même
beaucoup
moi j'avais toujours un problème avec
les ânes et adore parce que comme
c'était ses fonctions d'entraîneur vous
l'appeliez théodore faut le savoir
ah oui pardon oui c'est pas dire
autrement parce que la première fois que
je les ai vus ils voulaient déjeuner
avec moi il avait demandé à jean loin de
faire le déjeuner parce que jean nohain
faisait des échos dans marianne et
c'était la façon de
rencontrée je ne voulais pas et après le
déjeuner sam avait agacé j'avais 10 ans
théodore pareil je voudrais plus jamais
le voir j'ai dit tout à l'heure
malheureusement ça n'a duré que 14 que
40 ans mais il savait tout pour les
chansons aussi je l'appelais je lui
montrais le savez je comprenais tout de
suite il fallait pas faire ça il fallait
pas qu'on peut enlever ces mesures là
que vous allez vous vous disputiez sur
la télévision déjà si vous engueuler y
ait en disant des fois d'accord pas
tellement non non vous aviez peut pas
les mêmes milan oui c'est je comprenais
je comprenais skin expliquer ce qu'ils
disaient mais c'est vrai la raison
certains de vos amis ne trouvait pas
quand même un peu peu décevant que le
grand emmanuel berl s'intéressa à la
télévision non vous savez quand je quand
je revenais le petit conservatoire je
trouvais les deux petits enfants de
picasso les deux petits-enfants de camus
et avait toujours ça se passait comme ça
cocteau habitait la maison alors
théodore et nuit sur l'escalier est dans
l'escalier à 2 3 heures du matin en
pyjama je lis retrouver tous les deux à
lui chercher théodore en train de
discuter sur les émissions de télévision
est comme ça c'est plutôt voilà emmanuel
berl vraiment le prix de larmes et
beaucoup d'écrivains qui ont fait des
chroniques sur la télévision aujourd'hui
il y en a aujourd'hui encore mais
vraiment c'est le premier c'était
d'avoir un tel écart aussi important
dans l'histoire de notre profession à
nous ça nous savons très important c'est
la vie je remarque il écrit ça nous
avons deux exactement mais il écrit à la
fois pour candide et pour la nrl je
m'aperçois qui n'écrit pas de la même
façon pour les nouveaux candidats que
pour beaucoup mais primesautier rigolo
dans le mot candidats nrf c'est quand
même un peu plus sérieux le cinéma
français c'est grand lahou fait le
portrait de catherine deneuve donc d'ava
gardner
pourquoi parce que j'étais sorti kotone
mort j'ai fait je me sens très triste
oui m'enfin y'a beaucoup de comédiennes
qui me ravit technicien je vais
rencontrer qu'ils pouvaient l'avait
rencontré pour cible et mu
et puis bon catherine deneuve vous
vouliez savoir
finalement c'était un
cette île et leur jeu les gaullistes que
je te demande et du renard interview de
catherine jeudi les vues et des c'est
peut-être difficile
pourquoi c'est difficile parce que et
pas que je comprends très bien
non mais vous aussi vous parler plus
justement la tempête difficile et
pourtant et pourtant ça donne un papier
très réussi oui mais julie mal oui il ya
une piraterie qui dès mardi
et puis pour fellini alors là vous êtes
vraiment subjugué par fellini
ah oui oui je suis fumeur parce qu'il
vous amusez vous à c'est parce que
j'étais séduit chase des sites à tous
ces gens venus autour de lui parce qu'il
m'a pris sous le bras ils ont déjeuné
avec sa famille de les brûler
et puis d'une grosse et charmant alors
sam karmann je disais la transition oui
je fais ligny derrière ben pourquoi pas
vous pouvez devenir un très bon fini
vous êtes comédiens vous êtes metteur en
scène de théâtre
être comédien au théâtre et au cinéma
parce que vous avez joué dans cuisine et
dépendances et au théâtre et au cinéma
et puis vous êtes l'un des inspecteurs
de navarro avec roger hanin donc et puis
vous avez donc fait ce film
omnibus vous aviez metteur en scène de
ces deux théâtres vous vouliez depuis
longtemps vous essayer au cinéma oui oui
c'est vrai j'avais envie mais il fallait
que je trouve l'occasion et puis et puis
l'occasion s'est trouvée parce que c'est
une histoire de potes
cette histoire-là ses manies moi je la
trouve magnifique pour ça parce que
vraiment on a voulu se la préhistoire de
potes
une histoire de potes avec christian
rauth avec daniel rialet
avec chaque martial enfin tous ces gens
là sont des gens que j'ai rencontrés sur
la barre haut l'équipe technique que
j'ai rencontrés sur navarro qu'ils sont
venus pendant une équerre l'idée de ce
n'est pas non l'idée d'abord c'est au
départ une petite histoire vraie c'est à
dire que ça se passe comme ça dans les
trains il ya des moments de panique il
ya eu des témoignages
christian avec le témoignage de d'une
personne comme ça qui était absolument
terrorisé paniqué parce que il ya eu un
horaire et sa vie semblait bouleversé
peut-être pas au point du film mais ça
on part sur un drame quand on parlait
des gens qui font rire on parlait de
bernard blier tout à l'heure mais c'est
le tragique de bernard minne qui fait
rire il est tragique et c'est pour ça
qu'il est drôle et ce film je l' ai
démarré avec avec avec ses copains et je
leur ai dit ce qu'on joue un drame total
c'est un drame total jusque là jusqu'à
la fin et alors vous attendiez à paris
récompense jeu comment mieux bien sûr
que nous et bien sûr
et est ce que ça vous ouvre les portes
d'une mise en scène alors d'un grand
film le succès de serait tenté de le
croire quand j'en serai à la copie 0
demont au métrage entre le temps passé
entre maintenant et la copie 0 je vous
dirais oui j'ai eu la chance ou pas si
le temps est très longs jeux rue pas de
chance si le temps est raisonnablement
court janvier
alors je vous avais dit c'est le c'est
mon cadeau pour la centième de bouillon
de culture voici donc ce court métrage
qui je vous rappelle obtenu la palme
d'or à cannes et l'oscar à hollywood
puis quand même si un coup double assez
extraordinaire bon et bien donc vous
allez le voir il s'appelle omnibus et
huit minutes
huit minutes effectivement de tension
huit minutes d'humour et huit minutes de
bonheur
omnibus
[Musique]
bs et google
vous avez le complément jusqu'à dun
comment ça leur abonnement et sur
boulogne cateau cambrésis ce train est
directe jusqu'à lèvres je l'avais
complètement
vous n'avez pas le complément de
voltaire mais je suis obligé de vous
dresser un procès verbal
mais non monsieur je descends cadeaux
vous pouvez pas les 120 quintaux ces
trains directs jusqu'à d'elle
aulas 9h06 le 9h06 arrête les cathos
essieux le conte tous les jours depuis
six mois
ne me dites pas qu'il dirait que jusqu'à
d'oeuvre
il est direct après tout être mais celui
à s'arrête enfin j'en suis sûr je suis
dedans
vous travaillez peut-être à cateau
cambrésis mais moi je travaille dans ce
train et je vous confirme qu'à daté du
02 01 92 le 9h06 et directe jusqu'à
desvres ensuite il dessert les gares de
chapeau rouge
landré s'ils avaient sur elles et ils
arrivent à saint-omer à 11h16 02 01 92
secure puisqu'une aujourd'hui c'est ça
c'est maintenant c'est le 215 3 50 pour
le complément puissante rampe pour la
fraction ça vous fait 115 points 50
centimes chaque espèce mais c'est pas
possible on chante les horaires comme ça
c'est arbitraire le 1 peut-être mais
pour le tout
le 20 du mois on se méfie madame et mois
le dow s'est hâté crise
l'eau d'affichage j'ai vérifié il faut
perdre et monsieur
le seul qui s'arrête à cateau-cambrésis
center 35
sinon à desvres vous avez un service de
cars programme né là bas mais ça y est
je peux pas tous les sens
et que rien mais c'est catastrophique
115 3 et 50 centimes oui je vous donne
cet institut
bonjour part
[Musique]
monsieur vous êtes marié chaque maison
se marier des gitans
mais moi j'ai prêché ce travail là c'est
tout je suis à deux doigts de pire
licenciés c'est richie c'est richie peux
pas me supporter je sais pas ce que j'ai
fait c'est
c'est comme ça il mais est il m'a déjà
pu les deux avertissements
monsieur lecard même à fond il met au
moins 30 minutes c'est impossible je
serais mise à la porte
il n'attend que ça monsieur ma femme à
m'inquiéter c'est richie ne pas perdre
mon emploi turrel me quittes elle me
quittent les enfants vous avez pensé à
mes enfants
la dass et la tâche qui les attend
puisque ma femme ne travaille pas et que
j'ai un crédit sur le dos que je ne
pourrai plus payer une maison superbe
dans un lotissement une maison sans fin
une vie brisée monsieur époux parents et
ne quitterons la garde des enfants je
vous en prie
laissez-moi descendra cateau cambrésis
jeffrey vite on verra rien c'est toute
ma vie qui est en jeu
je vous en supplie
cateau cambrésis
moi je peux rien faire mieux
c'est pas moi qui peux arrêter ce train
possible
et vous monsieur
je vous emmener voir eyrolles nous
verrons bien ce qu'il vous dira
roj
mais rôle oui le conducteur il a fui
mais je vous promets rien
vous allez voir
et roche bobois du mans a dû jouer tous
les rôles
à
très beau
moi je travaille prix nous dit minois le
train ne s'arrête pas je le sais qu'il
suffit de le savoir
bien sûr d'autres aussi cautionné
florian faire pour vous voyez bien que
des contrôles et là
j'ai compris qu'on ne peut rien pour son
prochain quentin de la sécurité de
l'emploi c'est ça se passe assez con
pour y accoler chronique jet d'eau le
mans peut mourir approprié pour rester
sur bourail
c'est le prix
arrêté
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
carton cambrésis
je peux pas m'arrêter mais je ferai le
tir comment ça je vais courir
tu paies 13 secondes 4 juin à terre de
claye souilly
ça tombe bien vous allez trouver ça
n'est pas exactement ce que dira
c'est parti pour le compte à rebours aux
femmes en difficulté lorsque la vie
nationale
[Musique]
auj
aum
[Musique]
amiens
regardez vous avez failli rappelé
[Musique]
hahaha
peu après les attaques et alors mikel
michael nyman vous êtes vous êtes
compositeur musicien chef d'orchestre et
vous avez c'est vous qui avez composé la
musique du film de jane campion la leçon
de piano qui a obtenu la palme d'or à
cannes ont finalement n'est que dans les
palmes d'or ce soir
est-ce que alors je pose ça devait être
particulièrement difficile d'écrire la
musique de ce film parce que l'héroïne
est muette dont vous de venir raconter
tout ce qui se passe en aile à travers
la musique c'est un peu plus compliqué
que d'habitude je suis bien ça oui oui
j'y pense et plus j'en parle et
j'attache beaucoup depuis six jours
plus ça semble être appliquée
rétrospectivement il y avait le
personnage joué par pour les as tu un
personnage muet pour une raison ignorée
que je dirais les familles je confonds
de ce fait là la personne de relève en
turquie joue le piano il était vraiment
très importante que l'actrice elle-même
se joue parce qu'elle s'exprime par la
musique et il fallait que cette musique
serait que vraiment d'elle même et non
pas de l'entourage entre ce film et tous
les matins du monde au lit tout à fait
évident c'est que gérard depardieu et on
n'a pas cette 7 natation du jeu
cette complication supplémentaire de
l'année nous vivons dans une société de
1913 maintenant et j'ai créé quelque
chose et me sens et c'est une musique du
ce siècle ou du siècle dernier
je suis de ce siècle bien sûr moi même
mais il a fallu que je crée une musique
qui convaincre le spectateur comme étant
du siècle dernier et en même temps il
fallait que vous donnez à votre musique
une qualité je dirais d'érotisme
parce que cette femme s'exprime à
travers sa musique mais exprime son
corps ses désirs
en fin de contrat qu'elle servait de la
musique nous séduit sexuelle les films
de patrice j'ai déjà une certaine
expérience vous avez fait la musique
érotique sexuelle vous avez fait la
musique de monsieur habituel de
plus intense - ni risque plus qu'à nice
se voulait moins passionnés auxquels a
fallu que je ne met que rentrer dans le
cerveau humain je n'ai imaginé créé le
personnage joué par jouer un répertoire
de musique l'a opposée de celle chez un
autre je me suis imaginé un compositeur
et un tracteur en même temps que c'est à
dire est quelqu'un qui aurait supposé
2008 ce qui n'aurait pas été possible en
ce qui m'a permis d'ajouter certains
anachronismes des 100 autres soupçonnées
de se tromper et bien michael nyman si
vous voulez la gentillesse d'aller au
piano pour qu'on vous avez dû jouer un
petit morceau de la leçon de piano et
hop d'abord tous ceux qui ont vu le film
ils sont déjà nombreux en france je
crois qu'il n'a déjà plus d'un million
au moins je crois c'est beaucoup plus
d'un million et demi peut-être donc
voici vous voulez y aller
si vous voulez bien y aller ce morceau
pendant ce temps je vais montrer là je
vais montrer là ça vient de sortir parce
qu'on l'a le film est sorti à trois
semaines et tout le monde demandait la
musique de michael nyman parce
qu'évidemment cette musique joue un rôle
très important dans le film elle est
superbe
ça y est je sais pas s'il fallait alors
je suis pas sûr qu'il faut l'enlever
bref donc la musique de vous pouvez le
trouver dans ce dans ce cd qui vient de
sortir les choix qu'il était il est en
vente
ils étaient en vente je crois pour la
première fois aujourd'hui voilà deux
leçons de piano et on vous écoute quand
vous voulez
e
et
il
non
bon alors si glock est facile chez decca
la bande originale des films de peter
greenaway parce qu'il se lie man a fait
la plupart des films de greenway ce
sujet des cas et puis vous savez aussi
la bande originale du film de
prosper aux boucles chez decca aussi et
puis ça c'est son book chanté par ou
telle ampère musique évidemment de
michael nyman tp vous pouvez aussi en
cassette vous procurer la ou alors ça
c'est des les films de peter hill et wes
c'est drobny numbers et zoé et d'autre
le questionnaire c'est qu'on termine
toujours par le questionnaire françois
saillant à votre mot préféré s'il vous
plaît mots vous détestez obligatoires
notre drogue favorite
jj ce nouvel outil un vérin dutilleul le
son le bruit que vous aimez aimé revenir
son le bruit que vous détestez écrit
votre juron gros mot blasphème favori
caramba neuf hommes ou femmes pour
illustrer nouveau billet de banque
le métier vous n'auriez pas aimé faire
puis vint intervent pervenches lui la
plante l'arbre l'animal dans lequel vous
aimeriez être réincarné un chat est en
chasse qui est l'animal des écrivains et
aux records que vous ayez un chien vous
dansez et déjà marie qui s'appelle
fouillis oui et c'est le même nos deux
chiens que je sais plus qui quelqu'un de
l'autre jour c'est le même ah oui c'est
ça c'est josé artur un chien qui
s'appelle fouillis aussi et la chaîne de
trois ans et l'aînée dfb l'idf pour les
chiens ah bon mais il s'appelle fouillé
aussi à paris et enfin si dieu existe qu
aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire mes compliments
vous avez été parfaite
très bien mais c'est mes compliments à
la fin de cette émission voilà alors je
sens qu est mort aujourd'hui et nous lui
ferons une place la semaine prochaine
dans l'émission de bouillon de culture
de la semaine prochaine le alors je
termine par des ouvrages je signale que
julia reviendrait dit est à l'identique
bonjour tristesse
donc vous vous rappelez la première fois
ce bonjour tristesse
ce sentiment inconnu
comment ce sentiment inconnu dont
l'ennui la douceur m'obsède
j'hésite à apposer le nom le beau nom
gravé de tristesse ça c'est la première
fois ce qui a rendu célèbre
françoise sagan et puis 14 roman de
françoise sagan plus une pièce de
théâtre
les danseuses
c'est ce bouquin que j'avais déjà
d'ailleurs présenté à bouillon de
culture il y a quelques semaines le
alors josé artur je vous présentais des
choses un peu drôle à quoi je sers tire
les pensées de josé artur y avait quand
même d'assez extraordinaire par exemple
via celle ci j'ai arrêté d'envoyer des
vieux habits à l'abbé pierre ils ne les
mets jamais et puis celle ci l'amande ma
femme dit n'est tous les soirs avec nous
un jour je me suis aperçu que c'est moi
qui dînait avec eux ceci qui est pas mal
jean paul ii était un des rares polonais
avoir trouvé du temps du travail en
italie
et ceci qui est pas mal aussi payer
beaucoup de choses plus con qu'un pigeon
une boîte périmètre petits pois donc
c'est au cherche midi
vous avez ça vient de paraître aux daims
collection que sais je le rire d'eric
smadja et puis antoine de caunes a
préfacé une anthologie de l'os à moelle
38-40 la célèbre tous les quelques
années il sort d anthologie de pierre
dac des nôtres nos éditions françois
bourin
et puis cabu vous avez illustré ce livre
sur les beaufs d'aujourd'hui signé
frédéric brun de quelle liberté égalité
sacrée soirée aux éditions first
et puis je signale ce très bon wolinski
le bal des ringards aux éditions albin
michel politique et une exposition
d'ailleurs wolinski avec galerie daniel
delamare wolinski artistique sympathique
érotique esthétique etc
des dessins de bhl à champs sur le
tennis j'apprécie beaucoup la chance aux
éditions albin michel
et puis des dessins de
de reiser tam tam qui vont de 150
dessins 50 planches qui vont donner lieu
à des dessins animés
produit par canal + aux éditions albin
michel et puis aussi j'aime beaucoup
c'est pétillon imprimé dans la nuit
c'est les aventures de jack palmer aux
éditions albin michel l'écho des savanes
et puisqu'on n'a pas eu la télévision il
reste 5 minutes
alors là je te demande un petit des
bords mais toute façon vous ne pouvez
pas couper parce que je vais présenter
le livre de monsieur hervé bourges notre
patron alors si je vous prie alors là
alors je vous dis vous êtes viré la
suzuki couple a il est vrai bon alors
donc savez on dit toujours dans les
journaux nos collaborateurs plus monde
viennent de publier et bien les
collaborateurs de france 2 je crains
dans la mare oublier christine ockrent
les uns et les autres de mon tabac
balladur sont des portraits qu'elle
qu'elle fait sur france inter le
dimanche matin et il a vraiment l'art du
portrait christine aux craintes des
portraits des hommes politiques bien
entendu mais aussi des gens du spectacle
du sport
il ya même je crois elisabeth dont la
reine d'angleterre c'est très très bien
fait c'est aux éditions de l'aube
christine bravo avait fait les petites
bêtes ya pas longtemps il ya quelques
années maintenant elle récidive avec les
grosses bêtes c'est l'érotisme des
grosses bêtes aux éditions michel lafon
jean paul ollivier qui est l'un cycle
pdi du cyclisme publie delibes l'ange de
la montagne c'est charlie gaulle ça faut
lire savons évidemment le départ du tour
de france et le gobelet vous savez celui
ci se recoiffer toujours avant l'arrivée
des étapes
le suisse de le pédaleur de charme c'est
un suisse étonnant vous avez de livres
aux éditions glénat
un roman de bruno masure l'heure de
vérité audition plan mazurais imaginer
qu'en 1995 il ya un virus qui frappe
tout le monde vers le virus de la vérité
on est obligé de tout les gens sont
obligés de dire la vérité des hommes
politiques
les maris à leurs femmes enfin bref
c'est effrayant et c'est un livre à la
fois drôle et d'une certaine manière
effrayante édition plan et puis alain
d'anvers quel patron des rédactions de
la 2e et de la 3e publie un livre
passionnant sur l'environnement point
choc vers l'environnement dans tous ses
états tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur les
questions qu'on se pose environnement
aujourd'hui aussi bien la couche d'ozone
que la pollution
la nappe phréatique et c'est tout et là
dedans aux éditions numéro un et puis
donc hervé bourges hervé bourges la
télévision du public aux éditions
flammarion le patron du service public
ils disent que c'est que sa télévision à
lui et comment il l'a conduit et puis ce
point
non non je peux plus donner en off les
besoins encore non mais je suis pas fini
la télévision française par jean manuel
cortada au passé au présent hier au
stade de france la cohésion conseil et
puis si vous avez suivi le téléfilm qui
était avant avant bouillon de culture il
s'intitule meurtre en heure en ut majeur
et il était extrait il faillite et irait
plutôt de ce roman de maurice schumann
l'académie française qui paraît aux
éditions françois bourin
et puis le salaire du zappeur qui serge
daney qui était chroniqueur de
télévision à libération il est mort il
ya quelques mois et c'est les éditions
pel qui le publie donc quelques-unes des
chroniques de serge daney jeu j'ai parlé
de dubout voici à la réédition aux
éditions michel train nouvelles du
formidable rabelais de dubout c'est à
dire que c'est il a illustré c'est
merveilleux c'est extraordinaire c'est
vraiment absolument étonnant je suis ce
que vous aimez le jazz
vous avez beaucoup le jazz alors le
signal cv classique c'est la plus
importante collection de jazz fait à
deux la sortie de son 200e compact avec
duke ellington et sur la place de 1938
édition classique vous le voulez vous
l'offrir
voilà alors il ya un pic johnson 38 39
il ya johnny dot est là un lionel
hampton et son orchestre
si vous les voulez ils sont à bout
puisque vous aimez beaucoup le diacre et
et puis je signale je signale eu johnny
hallyday qui s'est pas pour cabut mais
la voile intégral de johnny hallyday
tous et tous et tous ces compacts voilà
tous aient cessé dé se savait en sortir
c'est extraordinaire ben si emmanuel
berl a été de là je lui offrirai entendu
ça va de soi je lui donnerai et alors ça
va de soi avec des livres sur du caïdat
y en a plein
comment ça va deux fois énorme succès
ensemble voilà alors je rêve m en
remercier et je termine là dessus c'est
terminé l'émission ont fini dans trois
minutes
je remercie alain gauvreau qui est
responsable de l'émission histoires
courtes qui a eu la gentillesse de me
céder votre film merci à lui voilà alors
histoires courtes c'est tous les
mercredis soirs où les jeudis matin
après le cirque de minuit c'est le banc
d'essai des jeunes auteurs des jeunes
réalisateurs et cette émission existe
depuis 10 ans et elle a été un tremplin
pour pas mal de déjà deux metteurs en
scène comme christian vincent leos carax
eric barbier et ses remerciements à tous
ceux journalistes réalisateurs
décorateur techniciens administratifs
qui ont collaboré et qui collabore à
bouillon de culture et puis j'ai une
pensée amicale pour michel gaillard sous
l'autorité duquel j'ai cette émission a
démarré et puis remerciements aussi à
mon patron hervé bourges qui m'attirait
du ghetto du dimanche soir il ya
quelques mois et c'était très bon pour
l'émission et puis remerciements à la
rejouer remercier vraiment leur version
spéciale à la fnac et à jean-louis
pétriat le patron de la gmf qui sont
vous savez des partenaires fidèles et
très généreux de bouillon de culture 2
plus le premier numéro c'est à dire que
fabricant culture le seul magazine
culturel sponsorisés commandé
aujourd'hui et ça fait deux ans et demi
et en dépit des difficultés du début
ils ont été vraiment une file d'une
fidélité extraordinaire alors il ya il
ya tous les représentants de la fnath et
directeur de la fnac qui sont ici je
peux pas tous les deux mais en fait des
shows pas les nommer mais soyez gentils
de dire jean louis pétriat mais mes
remerciements parce que c'est tout à
fait normal
cette ville et cette fidélité vraiment
extraordinaire et d'ailleurs la fnac
pour vous faire plaisir à l'initiative
de francis bueb qui est le directeur de
l'action culturelle du sur libre a tiré
à 100 exemplaires
françoise sagan 1
votre texte sur fellini et alors c'est
donc 100 exemplaires qui vous pourrez
distribué à vos amis c'est réservé aux
amis de françoise sagan voici le premier
exemplaire saison facile mais c'est très
beau voilà je sais que vous connaissez
pas beaucoup n'étaient pas encore très
bien
et puis vous pouvez voir un coup d'oeil
derrière c'est michel millecamps le
décorateur qui a inscrit cette semaine
les noms des bas des stars des vedettes
des écrivains des cinéastes des metteurs
en scène des acteurs qui sont passés à
bouillon de culture depuis deux ans et
demi
et à propos de la fnac je signale que
yelle actuellement se tient le festival
du film de paris au pont alexandre iii
et que demain à partir de 13h eh bien
vous pourrez vous pourrez vous y rendre
et vous y rencontrerez des vedettes du
cinéma du théâtre de la chanson et vous
pourrez vous faire photographier à côté
de ses vedettes
la faute au coût de 100 francs et tout
l'argent ira à perce-neige fameuse
fondation de lino ventura donc allez-y
je rappelle ses taux pour la reine pont
alexandre iii
voilà je crois que j'en ai fini le oui
je crois que j'ai fini alors je vais
vous remercier aussi mais inviter le
public aussi et puis les téléspectateurs
parce que évidemment c'est m fidèle
depuis donc pas mal de moi dont je vous
en remercie beaucoup ainsi se termine ce
centième bouillon de culture bonsoir à
tous et la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]